foreign
[Music]
things about the first few days
following a Zelda news drop is the Sheer
Drive and passion for making discoveries
and finding hidden secrets everyone is
collectively playing detective and
sharing their findings on places like
Twitter Discord Reddit and other
platforms and of course right here in
the YouTube comments more and more
pieces of the puzzle are being added by
the minute as people discuss ideas and
compare their findings so today let's
have some fun and cover five of such
discoveries details which I find
significant and could easily be missed
by those who aren't scrutinizing the
footage or keep a close eye on social
media every second of every day oh and
by the way I've already decided on a
more focused subject for a bigger video
and I'm happy to announce that it'll be
a collaboration with the man himself
Sarah Celtic and will go up sometime in
the middle of next week so I hope you
look forward to that until then grab
your magnifying glass and let's dive
into five discoveries found in The
Legend of Zelda tears of the Kingdom
if you played breath of the wild witch
I'm sure most if not all of you watching
my videos have you'll no doubt remember
discovering those huge mazes they were
one of the more notable and exciting
Secret locations in the game and there's
been a lot of mystery surrounding their
origin and the original purpose for
their construction and well it seems
that in tears of the Kingdom these
mysterious megalithic structures will be
taking off into the sky yes those Giant
floating cubes we've seen in some of the
shots are almost certainly the Labyrinth
so far we've been able to nail down two
of them with a high degree of certainty
the northern Labyrinth found in the top
right corner of hebra and the southern
labyrinth in the bottom right corner of
the Highlands that wrap around the grudo
desert we can see it most clearly in
this sequence here's the cube and if you
draw a line straight down to this
protruding Cliffside this is where the
northern maze should be but as you can
see it's no longer there we can find a
different floating cube in this shot and
once again if you follow the line back
down to the surface it matches exactly
with the original location of the
Southern maze which is normally tucked
away in this part of the mountains no
doubt I won't be the first to point this
out in a video in fact I totally missed
it in my initial analysis but one thing
I haven't seen a lot of people talk
about so far is that in this shot the
northern maze is still present on the
surface you can clearly see it still
standing right there it is easy to miss
because there's a different Revelation
in this shot which kinda overshadows it
that of course being the equally
mysterious typho ruins which is now
devoid of the black fog that covered it
in the previous title the fact that the
northern maze is still on ground level
here is significant on many different
levels first of all it's the only case
so far of a landmark we know from breath
of the wild that is taken to disguise
which is not the case with the other
islands and buildings we've seen in the
sky so far as they are all new and
unfamiliar secondly the fact that the
maze is on the ground in one shot and
then floating in another suggests that
link or someone else may have done
something to cause it to lift up into
the heavens triggered some kind of event
or completed some sort of task or
challenge inside the maze or maybe under
the surface below it sending it up into
the clouds it's also a pair apparent
that the labyrinths are much bigger than
we initially thought they were given the
fact that they are shaped like a cube
they seem to extend much further into
the Earth and the part of it we saw in
the previous game was maybe only the top
third or even fourth of the entire
structure that said there was one hint
to this reality in breath of the wild
lome labyrinth island situated in the
Arcola Province had an extensive
basement level which did show that it
was much bigger than we were able to
visually see from the outside however
the other two didn't feature a sub-level
of this size and so their actual size
wasn't as clear until now that is the
mysterious case of the floating
Labyrinth also presents the real
possibility that perhaps other
structures we know and love could also
lift up into disguise at some point
places like the great Plateau which also
had a big secret hidden under its
surface in the form of the final trial
or Hyrule Castle which has massive
tunnels and chasms deep below its
foundation so far the plateau and Castle
have still remained close to the surface
but who knows they might take off
through a similar process that caused
the labyrinths to take flight especially
the castle seeing its already suspended
in in the air to begin with it could
also be that only structures associated
with the zonai are eligible for a trip
to the sky after all there are clear
hints and connections between this
ancient tribe and both the Sky Realm and
the underground like I said so far the
labyrinths are the only case of known
landmarks originating from the surface
that are now floating above Hyrule and
they just so happen to be associated
with the zonai
[Music]
this next one is a bit more subtle and
maybe insignificant but you know those
new towers we've been able to spot all
across Hyrule well not only are there a
lot of them in closer places of interest
but they also seem to exert similar
Behavior as the original shika Towers in
most of the nighttime shots we can see
four bright spotlights at their base
which are pointing upwards making them
Stand Out From Afar just like the
original shika Towers did furthermore in
most cases the towers themselves are
seen glowing orange however in other
shots there are distant objects which
look to be the very same Towers this
time with a blue color instead of orange
I'm quite certain that these are the
same Towers in fact this one next to the
dueling Peaks might be the very same one
we see here in this shot just from a
different vantage point of course blue
and orange immediately calls back to the
sheikah whose technology like the
shrines and Towers glow orange when
dormant and blue when activated but
these towers are clearly not the same
ones from breath of the wild their
locations don't match I mean there
wasn't a shika Tower on top of Mount
laneru they also don't seem to Glow
during the daytime which if true is also
unlike the sheikah towers and yet the
colors orange and blue do at least
suggest a chica connection as opposed to
the other new technology most of which
have a green glow instead my running
Theory right now is that they are crude
more basic versions of the shika Towers
in some shots they look like they might
be made of wood or some other basic
materials like an old-school medieval
Watchtower I definitely don't think they
Rose from the ground like the original
chica Towers did because in some shots
you can see a gap at their base which to
me suggests that they are standing on
feet or a tripod or something perhaps
because the original Towers retracted
back into the ground and with no way to
get them to rise back up again the
current day chica improvised and built
crude replacements for them which would
have happened somewhere between the
ending of breath of the Wild and the
beginning of Tears of the Kingdom it's
arguable if anything from age of
Calamity should be considered Canon or
not since it's a spin-off but here we
did see the shika recreating technology
that mimics those from their distant
ancestors case in point being the small
portable furnaces us which mimic the
much larger ancient furnaces from 10 000
years ago
[Music]
by now we've all seen those strange
looking green spirals coiling around
some sort of rock or Spire they're all
over the place in many different shots
usually tucked away far in the
background many are speculating that
these might be this game's equivalent of
fast travel points just like the shrines
and Towers did it's worth mentioning
that so far all of these spirals are
found on the surface and we have yet to
see a single one on the islands in the
sky so either they are limited to
letting you fast travel to locations on
the surface only and getting to the
islands will require different methods
or they serve as a connection between a
point on the surface and in the sky I
did mention in my video about the new
mechanic where link phases through
ceilings that the description inside the
pattern say that in some cases this jump
can be performed with virtually no
height limit so maybe when link stands
on top or close to one of these spirals
he'll be able to soar upwards rapidly to
a designated Island it would explain why
none of these spirals are found on the
islands themselves perhaps the only way
to activate these warp points on the
surface is from the skies above after
which link will have established quick
access to a specific Island so he can
get back there more quickly in the
future maybe that's what some of these
weird buildings are for as some of them
do seem to have a sort of altar which
could be used to activate these fast
travel points down below and yes it's
almost certain that these spirals do
need to be activated and are not there
by default because in the shot where
link is riding his horse across Hyrule
Field we can see one of these fires or
rocks this green coiling energy emanates
from yet here the spiral is absent and
in fact I'm quite certain that this
location is the very same one we see in
one of the earlier nighttime shots you
can even see the same pools of malice
right beside it and here the spiral is
present which hints that this shot takes
place after it's been activated in this
one before link has done so
so this is a short one because I don't
really have a whole lot to say or
theorize about it but did you know that
there's additional footage we didn't see
in the original trailer people have been
able to dig up some sort of compilation
video I think from one of the Japanese
websites which features extended
versions of some of the trailer
sequences most notable are this shot
which wasn't even in the trailer at all
this one where link is driving the car
which lasts a good few seconds longer
and reveals more of the surrounding
landscape on the left and right side and
the short ways riding that new flying
machine which shows a second floating
sphere in addition to this one also not
visible in the original footage
the great Plateau shows up a couple of
times in the new footage most notably
this close-up shot and there's a few
where it's also visible in the distance
but it makes another appearance and here
it reveals a pretty important detail
this part of the plateau which faces the
desert is normally covered in snow but
as you can see not only is the snow gone
but there's trees and vegetation growing
here now which is very strange however I
do think I have a plausible explanation
for it and no it's not time travel so
remember how after the 2021 teaser a lot
of people were pointing out that the
sun's location seems to be different the
main gist of it is that it's in a point
in the sky it never reached before
because of the way the day and night
cycle worked in breath of the wild
normally the sun would travel like this
it never reaches south of the latitude
of Hyrule Castle it always passes by its
northern side but in the teaser footage
the sun was clearly located a lot more
to the South and in fact we see the same
thing again in the new footage so this
hasn't been changed since in other words
shadows in breath of the wild will never
reach the angles we saw in the teaser
footage you can test this yourself as
was to be expected this would ignite a
debate regarding the possibilities of
time travel after all why else would
this unchanged position like this so
drastically unless it takes place in a
different age or something however I and
some others proposed a different
explanation at the time and that is
simply a season change in real life
depending on where you are the sun's Arc
across the sky changes significantly
between winter and summer in the winter
it stays closer to the Horizon leading
to lower temperatures whereas in the
summer it travels up higher I think this
serves as a solid explanation for the
sun's shift in tears of the Kingdom we
don't know exactly how much time has
passed between the two games but judging
from the landscape changes Zelda's new
hairdo and other factors like the Divine
beasts being completely gone it's hinted
that there is a significant time Jump of
at least a few months so maybe breath of
the wild took place closer to the winter
season and tears of the Kingdom closer
to summer we can still see what looks
like snow higher up on the mountains
which makes sense given the elevation
but a shifted the summer would explain
why the snow at the edge of the plateau
which is closer to ground level has now
receded the only hole I can find in this
explanation is that in this shot the
plateau's wall also looks a bit
different more pristine and undamaged
which is definitely strange one could
say well maybe they fixed up the plateau
in between games but if that's the case
for some reason they only did it on this
side of the plateau because on the other
side it's still heavily damaged on some
spots but who knows maybe the wall just
looks different because of the
perspective or because the snow is gone
it somehow makes it look unfamiliar or
maybe my whole season shift theory is
just completely wrong that's also
possible of course at least there is
still some hope left for the proponents
of time travel and that wraps it up for
today I will probably do another one of
these in the near future because I have
plenty more of these types of little
discoveries ideas and theories to share
and not all of them are big enough to
devote an entire video to in fact the
original idea for this video was to
feature 10 of them but as always I end
up writing a much longer script than I
expected so I will say save the rest for
later I want to keep the content flowing
in the next few weeks and shorter videos
definitely help with that once again I
will save the patreon and member shout
outs for a bigger video the Celtic
collab to be precise I did update the
end screen as you can see which I
actually did before the direct but
there's still some people missing
particularly the ones who joined during
the live stream so no worries I will
give you all the shout outs you deserve
including the people on screen right now
just give it a few more days anyway that
is all for now and I will see you all
next time